so no one told you honest trailers was
gonna put this out today that doesn't
really work friends is my favorite show
of all time
next to Breaking Bad I know it's kind of
weird and honest trailers it's one of my
favorite segments on YouTube put two
together this is gonna be awesome yeah
John's not in today plus he's only seen
like some of friends I'm a purist when
it comes to the ship we roll back into a
regular schedule tomorrow in the
meantime let's check this out you
watched it for free on TV then you paid
to watch the reruns on DVD you paid to
watch the reruns again on cable and you
paid to watch the reruns again again on
that with no back get ready to pay HBO
max - what same reruns again again again
only this time it comes with an all-new
reunion special again that's been
indefinitely postponed we even our year
friends welcome to turn the century New
York where coffee shops are more than
just a place to charge your phone the
sweaters are extra chunky and the
furniture etiquette is just awful get
your feet o the couch and meet the
friends there's Joey an aspiring actor
slash human garbage disposal and how
much you give me to eat this whole jar
of our soap you pleased to call me a
human garbage disposal they should be
facing up not down because the head of
the bed is where the Sun would be you
want to put the marshmallows in
you don't know her brother Ross that
goes from depressed nerd someone at work
ate my sandwich semantically stable
buffoon in ten short years a city
haircut have been only speaking
complaints I'm like officially sucks so
this is Brooklyn
he made Rachel cry oh god your manchild
who uses humor to run away from his
psychological issues I have issues with
commitment intimacy I make jokes when
I'm uncomfortable I'm hopeless awkward
and feeding she's a wannabe musician
with a mother who committed suicide
my mom killed herself and a stepfather
in prison you know how my stepdads in
prison causing her to grow up in the
streets in a box I used to beg for money
I'll tell you about the time I stabbed
the cop who's estranged identical twins
don't identity to do Pam spinner her
mouth to my name and shame on you and
the dead woman she thought was her
mother wasn't actually her mother and
her real mother was alive the whole time
I'm Your Mother
you know what this is too depressing
let's just call her the weird one the
only crazy
[Music]
was like in the 90s we a history book or
something I know but if you want to know
what a sitcom set in New York in the 90s
was like friends is the show for you
watch the sporadically unemployed
20-somethings living multi-million
dollar Park New York that would be a
sensible idea watch as they consume some
of the finest legally clear both
products of the decade like Donny water
Nilla wafers diet Apple whoa I've never
noticed that oh here we go
waiter receptionist co-worker you never
see again
sassy Rothstein and I used to Thailand
and two of roses short-term girlfriends
yeah come on how an Julie yeah right
let's give them a round of applause for
doing the bare minimum
through it all experience the ups and
downs of one of TV's worst love stories
Ross and Rachel
two of the least compatible people in
entertainment history watch this
neurotic intellectual and the spoiled
anti intellectual clash as Ross likes
Rachel then Rachel likes Ross - Ross is
a girlfriend so Ross dumps his
girlfriend hates Rachel but they
immediately break up didn't get back
together didn't go on a break did break
up again then Rachel decide she likes
Ross again so he dumps another
girlfriend
so he says they're only at the altar and
gets divorced but nowhere else doesn't
want to get together than they mostly
three to pregnant but they don't get
back together but also they're jealous
of each other but also they still decide
not to get together Rachel decides to
move to Paris and rejects Ross but that
immediately changes in mind they
actually do get together just in time
for the series finale are you people
cheering for I give this thing ten
minutes tops
they probably wouldn't worry oh the
unforgettable moments you love chemin de
Lamballe Regina for LAN Chi dr. drake
ramoray just know what you're signing up
for because when you watch this weekly
show all at once you start noticing
things like now inexplicably horny the
characters are that's a very sexual very
fast and data thing of gold the studio
is can you see my nipples through this
shirt the thin layer of gay panic that
covers every yeah let your risk
that's the realization that every
character in the show has just one
reaction to literally anything that
happens there's also a lot of what oh my
god oh stop it
starry cougar town origins
fangs of New York Ross Dress for Less
Fiona crapple matt LeBlanc look on its
face The Big Bang Theory
9 3 the Jenny the one from screen
junkies hooking up with relatives you
don't kiss your friends mom that's right
how told me that at a movie fight for
Joey sister
Jim getting handsy I ever panties right
down my door
mine is the red one you took your eggs
and you're like this is capital R
capital T I want to go through the
tunnel to the other side
you're the worst best man you freaked
out don't touch me I'm only human good
I'd never be any good that shot be any
prettier could I could I be more sorry
[Music]
bad dizzy no said it goes the Monica and
Chandler
I know how to do the Chandler dance
[Music]
this is I can at bay come on long honest
travel it's ten years ago I know
ugly naked guys master ugly naked guys
LAN kitchen tile ugly naked guys taking
his turkey out of the oven ugly naked
guys decorating his tree ugly naked guys
using his new hammock ugly naked guys
gonna make it ugly naked guy with funky
stuff ninety stuff that's what do you
role avoid laserdisc marathon Walker
Texas Ranger Yasmine Bleeth Sony
PlayStation's oh I bought a Foucault
swing dance Tom Hanks Meg Ryan they get
male ones by 2 Chicken Soup for the Soul
[Music]
stupid gap on every corner
how you doing how you doing how you
doing how you doing how are you doing
how you
[Music]
Robin Williams yeah wrap it you show
Brad Pitt I heard that character isn't
like how do white people so starting
early off-broadway production of
interstellar I'm gonna get on this
spaceship
[Music]
but when I returned two hundred years
from now you'll be long gone but I want
to be aged at all
[Music]
fascinating maybe Nolan to get his idea
for shows that'll scratch that friends
edge and click right yeah hang out with
your screen junkies friends on sju our
daily pop culture morning show it's
worth it pivot pivot pivot trot how're
you doing oh I think the gong boxes
would have so much and friends coats the
sec ah man that was an epic one very
long epic when honest trailers writers
when they decide to do like a TV show
one day they do watch every single
episode I don't know if every one of the
writers does actually watch every
episode or if they're like you watch
this is and I'll watch this season but
they coulda did their homework because
they span all of the ten seasons here's
major credit to everyone who assembled
this because as an assembly piece this
is a lot of hard work you got to do all
the writing you had all the coverage of
all the episodes and all the editing as
well great voiceover work by John Bailey
this is an epic was like over ten
minutes long ten seasons it's
appropriate it's appropriate I was kind
of surprised but I guess they didn't
include Paul Rudd in the guest stars
part because I don't think Paul Rudd was
the Paul Rudd that he is now like if he
guest-starred on it on a sitcom with a
live audience now and he just showed up
I'm sure the crowd would cheer for who
Paul Rudd is now but back then I
remember he was introduced as Mike and
he was like one of the main reassuring
characters like most of the last season
he's in the last episode of the show
that now he would get that that praise
and attention shuts out Paul Rudd as
Mike and it's so true with Phoebe's life
man she did have a pretty dark life and
when you strip away the humor behind the
craziness it really is a tragic tale of
Phoebe which I find very fascinating of
how they managed to like we always
resort to Phoebe is kind of like the
wild card kind of a bit of an airhead
sort of character but she's Lisa
Kudrow's incredible in the role she I
mean the show wouldn't be complete
without her it's just funny to know that
actually really dark stuff of what she
goes through the other thing I would add
on to the reoccur
lines that they do like the oh my god
joke a lot of the time a character will
say something weird and then the other
one will go what friends is not
exclusive to that joke but that is a
very common type of additional joke on
top of a a weird joke that someone has
said or some weird comment that someone
has said and they go what I've been
watching this show since I was a little
kid I still love the living hell out of
it the older I get especially by the
time I reach my mid-20s which I'm still
in my mid-twenties by the time I reached
where I am now the more I identify with
the show when you watch it as a kid it's
funny then you as you get older you
start to identify more especially in the
earlier parts of the show like the first
few seasons really identify with that
part yeah they have a great point like
the show in a lot of ways this is like
this it's a sex comedy show there's so
much sexual humor in here that most of
the episodes because they're careful
with the way they formulate their
language this is like a PG version of a
Judd Apatow comedy and a lot of what is
the amount of censorship they do towards
vulgarity but they're always talking
about that kind of subject and I think
that's kind of just a 90s thing as well
not saying it's okay but the effect of
what they call it here I like the word
they use gay panic be it uncomfortable
with anything gay related yeah that's
that that's true that that's definitely
in the show but I think it's enough I
think that lasted that kind of bit in
other comedies and other shows up until
like the early 2000s it's what kind of
exists today not as much friends was
definitely no exception to that
and with the way how Ross and Rachel are
they are very toxic for each other in TV
world like I cry at the end of the show
when Ross is listening to the answering
machine the voicemail of Rachel on the
plane and he's like did you get off the
plane and then rachel says I got off the
plane like I cry whenever I get that
last moment in the show of course you
root for them there Ross and Rachel
realistically speaking though I don't
think they would make it work
undoubtably at least five out of six of
them maybe six out of six should
probably go see you know a therapist
Ross Rachel are very toxic for each
other my buddies in the last season
there's this whole thing where rachel
gets pregnant they have their baby Emma
in the last season she's
most non-existent been Ross's first
child becomes pretty much non-existent
and then Emma
especially becomes non-existent there's
a whole debate about Rachel is offered a
job in France or something she's torn
between moving to France or staying in
New York and the Schultz of m'ladies
chooses not to have the job and stay
back in New York and be with Ross I
think there's maybe like one line
brought up about Emma and that whole
thing if even then right even sure about
that this kind of baffles me that you
guys have a kid and the idea of you
having a daughter doesn't seem to be a
prevalent conversation and the whole
thing of traveling between New York and
Paris like that that could be a strain
on a kid for their parents to be that
far separated and for the travel and
everything when I was younger deaf %
everyone called me Chandler I made a
conscious choice it was in the first
season Chandler is talking with a
therapist he's not in therapy it's a
Phebe's this is a guy she's dating he
points out that she the he that Chandler
uses humor as a defense mechanism and I
remember people like but like Letten not
even ten years old and going I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna apply that I was
definitely more of a Chandler I'm body
the Matthew Perry personality as I was
getting older I definitely morphed into
a more Chandler and then to a Ross now
recently I I'm pretty sure I'm more of a
children without the crazy sacks like
I'm I'm definitely more of a Joey kind
of personality which you know what he
got his own spin-off so as much he might
be the stupid one on the show whatever
matt LeBlanc he's killing on TV still
kind of Joey was cancelled anything
friends related I'm just excited to
watch I'm excited for the reunion
especially hope all of them are there
because there was one reunion a few
years back when Matthew Perry wasn't
able to be there because he was doing
some play I think in London this time
around all of them should be there even
though I owned all the DVDs whenever I
end up watching friends it is through
some type of streaming service Thank You
honest traitors for putting this
together
anything friends related is always a joy
for me to watch it's funny with like
when there's already so much like
character exposition in a show all they
got to do is kind of highlight that and
repeat what the show's already saying
has a breakdown of the characters
instead of having to make jokes about it
it should be like a movie in the future
that's a the way they had it at Mary
Tyler Moore Show then they did that
drama Lou Grant they should do that but
with Ross and Rachel birth like marriage
story with Ross and Rachel that would
make the fans really happy all right
guys I favor done so already subscribe
to the reel rejects click that
notification Bella get notified never
got a new YouTube video up subscribe to
screen junkies if you haven't done so
already
hey last but not least annual gala
Connor out of threaten from Scotland you
know what hit me recently is that we've
been chatting on and on for like two
three years now I realize I don't really
know that much about you if you go
through our messages on patreon we have
like monologues going back and forth but
there are usually like pop-culture movie
related I know that you're in Scotland I
know I know that Batman was Phil near
you I know he's like a lot of movies and
shows I know you're working the
pharmaceutical industry but I don't
really know much about you as an
individual and we're friends on Facebook
so dude if you happen to catch a
shout-out I'm using this to encourage
you to be more of a real friend in my
life and let me know a little bit more
about your personal life that way I
could expose it here on the channel and
get you cancelled internet police coming
your way Daniel